good morning good afternoon or good
night but welcome to another episode a
big movie that's right we got your boys
here
it's Bo's who else we got oh we just ate
lunch and I'm so sleepy right now this
is great that's Gina obviously
complaining and tired I'm TIFF and I'm
Jessica and today we're gonna be kind of
free balling it but we're gonna be
talking about uh booties
butt holes plan B genitals in a corset
old and everything in between we kind of
just decided like we don't really talked
about six in a while and we didn't know
what to talk about talk about sex baby
that's not made my son come from when I
was a kid like why she's on the radio
and I'm riding in the car with my
grandparents and [ __ ] oh I remember
singing when I was little and I didn't
know what I was singing a my mom was
like don't say that I think the word
saxophone in some way was related to sex
so every time I would hear the word
saxophone I would go like any time
something sexual has come on and I was
with my parents I would be like oh god
disgusting I don't want to look at that
no horrible and like my mom at this
point is probably like my mom she would
cover my eyes when I whenever there was
a kissing scene in a movie or a TV show
and I just it made me so much more
curious and that like much more like
horny or whatever as a kid because I'm
like I need to see like I miss it a fact
yeah exactly I just felt so like
deprived of it a quick school effect
yeah my grandparents for some reason
about that anything at all that's not a
cartoon is an adult show so I'll be
watching Disney Channel they'll walk in
and they'll be like are you watching
adult things well you want to watch
adult B's I'm like look it's like it's
like icarly she look at the focus is
maybe they were watching some adult
things gosh she's gross she's old now
did you ever catch your parents watching
but I caught my mom with porn on the TV
before I caught my stepdad
it's so disgusting I remember exactly
the like the shitty apartment that my
mom and I were living in and I walked
from my bedroom into the living room and
it was this weird creepy porn of he's
like it's like a living room I don't
know she has a bedroom I guess maybe she
didn't have a TV in her bedroom I can't
remember
but it was these old creepy like white
people like old and creepy looking ones
I really like out of shape just nasty
ugly old manager porn kind of stuff I
guess but they were like it was kind of
like some hippie [ __ ] they were like all
naked outside they had a picnic blanket
on the ground d'etat yeah oh but like
gross white people like nasty like ugly
gross ones they're all [ __ ] outside
on this picnic blanket and I just
remember looking at that like I walked
out I stood in the living for for a few
minutes and I was looking at it like oh
I don't know she wasn't there for some
no I thought you made she was there
don't look Jessica reason she I don't
remember her being there but I remember
like it was on the TV and I was watching
and I was like what the [ __ ] so maybe
she had already watched it and then like
moved on to the bathroom or something I
just couldn't wait to the boat god that
was a little bit disgusting and
traumatizing but there's some reason I
was a very sexual child so even though
that creeped me out and is absolutely
disgusting I was still the child that
was like I was masturbating in
elementary school while most people were
ma'am we're waiting until handle or
heist a lot of little certain elementary
I've met some kids before too like yeah
I was like 10 years old I remember
having my first orgasm - it shocked the
[ __ ] out of me I was an elementary
school Jesus I was like I was like oh
this is great I [ __ ] love this this
is [ __ ] great and I couldn't wait and
then with the first time I had my orgasm
I was like huh I was like oh like what
and I was like it felt like it didn't
feel good at the time remember the
orgasm was not the fun part I like the
part up before that but then the orgasm
was like shocking and it was just like
oh my god this is like it didn't feel
good it was almost like I got
electrocuted
dude jess is out here coming in
elementary school meanwhile one time I
swallowed a bead and I thought I was
gonna die marble is around the same time
- and I almost choked at the time I was
just man you were taking out early and
swallowing marbles
I didn't have my first orgasm until
Iowa's maybe like 23 or 24 in the
twenties yeah I didn't like 16 yeah I
tried but I was like that doesn't feel
good you guys are all stupid and I don't
know dude same but I kept going until I
figured it out
I remembered like a few times I had just
tried it I was like well let's see what
this is all about and but I never like
watched a porn or anything but I do
remember like being like really really
young and you guys know that thing on
the playground where it's just like a
like a little pipe and you can just like
go down like a fireman's like a fireman
yeah I remember going down that one time
and I was like yeah that doesn't sound
good to me
oh yeah it just goes right down hard and
colder I don't know another warm sunny
day Oh cuz that was me too in elementary
school I I think I've said this before
to where I remember being I think in the
second grade and playing in the
playground and like being on the one of
the monkey bars or not the monkey bars
it's another one like the gym jungle gym
and stuff and then oh no I remember what
it is
you know those gymnastic bars that every
level is a double layered level bars
yeah yeah so I remember being on one of
those and like just humping the [ __ ] I'm
like oh my god this feels so good it's
so funny because like you're doing it in
public too but I think I already knew
what it was so I was never doing that
and you know I was never doing that in
public but I would go home and I would
close my door I would turn my little
ninja turtles around so they couldn't
walk and like you know that the firemen
pole thing like any other kid is like
using the base of their feet and they're
not even on the pole
and I'm like all right here we go down
slow they're like you know I'm not
concerned about Bose all she does just
go up and down now she's the only child
that's ever gone up and down moving your
pelvis though like I remember actually
humping it like I remember I don't I was
just being discreet I think I knew
something unholy was going on and so I
was just dropping it holding I was I
know I was too dumb I didn't know what
was happening and then but then I think
I don't know how I figured it out but
eventually I think I figure it out
because I didn't do it that many times
and we liked what with two or three
times and then eventually I figured out
like because every time I was doing it I
was like in my own world like the rest
of the world didn't exist over there
like dude for real I mean like I said I
walked in a stepdad watching it and what
he was watching was like these
late-night HBO shows oh yeah turning
like soft porn yeah yeah and so it was
so ridiculous because at that time I
remember exactly - I was 11 years old
and during that time I had this like
really weird thing where I wanted to I
wanted my bedroom to be as tiny as
possible so I actually moved into my
walk-in closet yeah like I moved my
child remove my twin size bed into my
walk-in closet and then I decorated like
the rest of the closet with like posters
where at fort yeah what is it
masturbation cause you know no I wasn't
even masturbating at this point yet so
then um you're like a dog you wanted a
cave yeah I just wanted to be like super
tiny like sue and then I remember when I
would go to sleep at that time to I
would sleep up against the wall with
like my nose touching the wall like I
needed to be like I don't know I had
issues so anyway so then we're also
eating glue
I never liked I liked play-doh anyway so
then the walk-in closet wasn't small
enough for me so I wanted to move into
that that under the stairs
action cabinet duh pretty much like you
know where Harry Potter and everything
so but it was too small to fit a
mattress I to sleep on the floor anyway
so I remember I only lasted like a week
there cuz I was literally like this and
I'm like man my body hurts I can't sleep
in the [ __ ]
but one of those nights I could hear the
TV and it was on and I could hear I hear
moaning and stuff I'm like what the [ __ ]
so when I opened the door and I could
see that my stepdad was on the couch and
he was watching this like HBO softcore
[ __ ] and I was just getting back and I
was like staring at it and I was like
whoa but then I felt so disgusted and
creeped out that it was him watching it
like we didn't have a good relationship
at all so I was I think I only started
it for like 15 seconds 20 seconds and
then I was like good close it and then I
was just like oh my god oh my god what
is he watching no you was there so I'm
like you probably thought you were
asleep
probably because it was really late but
yeah it was just like I was traumatized
did you have you ever caught your
parents having sex no I killed myself my
dad no my parents different people never
had sex
they have no they've never no they'd
never had sex my stepmom it might be my
stepdad or my real my mother has never
had sex with anybody we are the product
of Immaculate Conception absolutely my
the only one let's call my parents
having I walked in after my mom and my
stepdad had sex it's all dinelli
40-year old [ __ ] to me thinking about
anytime like like you've ever had that
sneaky sex before we got it over with no
one's ever gonna find out but like now
that we know what like sex has a sense
like it really does read and like sweat
ya mean has a smell to
I'm on your stomach like and then they
spread that [ __ ] around with a towel
you're walking around and you smell like
really good like that it's just me or
does every penis kind of smell the same
they all to me well if they're all
uncircumcised they all smell a little
bit like piss to me because it's like it
gets trapped in their looking skin only
been circumcised okay well I think maybe
one time there was an uncircumcised but
all of them there's a very distinct
penis sweat smell I know yeah right now
I just got a little a little memory I
think it might be the smell of calm
there might be this recom probably tear
it by the time they kind of pre [ __ ] a
little bit literally as soon as I walked
through the door it activates the
pre-cana I feel like you know like when
you have a baby and you have like that
first what's that stuff called TIFF like
the very when you first breastfeed you
have that like oh yeah like that plug or
whatever the mucus excuse me or no what
is it
I don't remember I don't [ __ ] know
but anyway so like the very first time
you breastfeed like all this extra they
call me like golden like the golden it's
like a good [ __ ] right but I'm sure it's
probably low rank it's like the rankest
part of the come like so I feel like
that Joran yeah pushing through the
penis right so like the [ __ ] is like
pushing through the bits like kind of
cleaning out the urine before the [ __ ]
call my god that's a crazy big part that
freaks me out the old nipple milk things
still [ __ ] this oh sorry so bad right
it's gonna happen it's gonna happen but
I can't I just can't believe y'all y'all
think balls have a distinct oh they do
yeah kinda it's a little bit musty but
not too bad usually even if they shower
I can kind of smell like you know the
Heather green or like whatever that you
know that's sick right and then they're
still like all skin dude that when a guy
mom turned it off when a guy takes a
shower and he in like in like if they
like shave a little and like clean it up
and they've just freshly washed
everything like I mean like they
no they're getting laid tonight it's got
that faint smell a ball yeah Oh smell
sit on my trim dan you're at a guy's
house - I won't probably wash my face so
I wake up and I still have that [ __ ]
ball smell on my face
that's your hands yeah like even just in
your saliva like I'm looking down my
smell if I get on my hands after like
you know like you give someone a blow
job it's what cuz all your spit and then
you jack them off yeah the smell of spit
is on your hands I think oh you better
go wash er yeah you like watch my hands
get up and spit and wash my hands I'm
talking about sex has the distinct like
not just like not just like the girls
scent but also the guys and when those
smells combined like it's like I don't
know the pheromones or something it's a
very distinct smell
and then the spit on top of that like
dude you are not fooling anyone if you
[ __ ] your boyfriend then your parents
walking no there's no yeah yeah I go
into my - you guys is the y'alls [ __ ]
smell real bad after they come inside oh
if it sits in there dude inside of me
because that shit's gonna sit in there
for two or three days even if I try to
wash it out actually no company it's
[ __ ] sits a fairy it's like rank is
my ass haribol it's [ __ ] we're trying
to have a kid you had a kid oh and that
too but I'm saying like now like I don't
I never smelled it after it throws off
my pH yeah maybe maybe for us it throws
off our because every time I've had come
inside of me I have to immediately
[ __ ] like take a garden hose it's
gonna smell in two or three days that's
it's it's up there [ __ ] swimming
around it needs to come out smell it
like when you appear something or what
it comes out of the weight comes out -
yes
comes out and then UPI just smells like
ya is baby because you guys don't want
kids that's why it stinks yeah sweet
flower like oh yeah the baby's gonna
come out of this my body is like
actively rejecting like ya got here
right now you stink yeah yeah
damn no you know if you if you let your
if you let your downstairs smell bad you
should at least clean your upstairs Oh
like maybe your hair oh my god you guys
how like my vagina might smell after
someone comes in in but my hair hey so
functional beauty is a custom-made
shampoo for your hair type however
however whatever hair you have you go on
their website and you take a little quiz
and you tell them what kind of hair you
have and what hair goals you want and
they custom make a bottle of shampoo and
conditioner for you and everything is
custom down to the color and the smell
even the bottle and the best part is the
bottle has your name on it it says
function of Gina mine is pink and it
smells like peach like my vagina this is
the Internet's top-rated customized hair
brand over 30,000 five-star customer
reviews and Counting curly or straight
natural or process function of beauty
individually formulates every bottle
based on your unique hair type style
preferences and hair goals plus function
of beauty is vegan and cruelty free they
never use sulfates parabens
philately cows mineral oils or any other
harmful ingredients
I know exactly what every single one of
those ingredients are so for me I have
very thin hair kind of dry and my scalp
is dry as hell so I told them that and
they made this bottle for me and like
they you can also add like this minty
feel to it so it makes yourself feel
like super minty so it I smell like a
minty peach when I come out of the
shower and then I have the pink one like
I said to get started right now go to
function of beauty.com slash big mood
to take part or to take your four-part
hair profile quiz and save 20% on your
first order don't spend another minute
in hair misery go to function of
beauty.com slash a big mood to let them
know that we sent you that's function of
beauty
slash slash big well once your hair is
fresh some hellofresh is disappointed in
us right this is like guys game if you
guys have been following my Instagram
lately you will have noticed that I've
been posting my hello fresh meals so
good I think one of the first ones I
posted was this port this fig fig you
saw me I tried so good is good and then
I also did the parmesan crusted chicken
no one's baked actually but you just
like like stack a bunch of garbage on
crusted [ __ ] on top of it
favourite the I never know how to cook a
chicken fight me I wanted to taste dude
the parmesan crusted chicken is so good
it was my first hello fresh meal and
after that I was like alright screw the
sponsorship I'm just gonna go buy this
myself yeah no I actually bought some
more even though we they gave us some
free ones sponsorship I bought some more
myself because they're so delicious one
thing that's crazy about that is that
you put sour cream over the chicken
breast and then you like stack a bunch
of parties it's so maybe a few years ago
is so good I went out and bought the
ingredients for it solo just to make it
at home yeah yeah so uh the what hello
freshers is pre-portion ingredients so
you don't really have to prep there's
like less food ways it's flexible I
actually what I like to do is I don't
like to cook every meal so I'll order
one one week I'll skip the next week so
I can go out to eat a few times and I'll
order again for the following week so
like every other week I like to cook and
then every other week so I like that
their plans are flexible you don't have
to always do it I also love if you are a
single person or living in a single home
like myself I make what you get a two
porch like two portions of meals so I
make both portions I have one for dinner
that night and then I take the other one
to lunch from me exactly that's what I
do yeah and I think the portions are
like like less than five dollars a piece
so it's wage
her than buying lunch at work than like
you know some of those delivery apps can
get expensive or maybe you're just one
person and you order the four people
family plan for yourself
let's get them get the most meal for
your moolah go to hell afresh calm slash
big mood 10 and use code big mood ten
for ten free meals including free
shipping bomb you know you got to eat
you guys well try it go to hello fresh
calm / big mood 10 and use code big mood
10 for your 10 free meals and free
shipping so good I love the food chicken
fajitas cuz normally I'm just like I put
the vegetables and the chicken in the
pan and I'm like it's a fajita but they
give you all the spices yeah we already
had lunch and I'm getting hungry anyways
back to like crusty [ __ ] right so
apparently has a perfect vagina where
the semen just rips right out after it
makes it lights it up and it's like
she's pregnant and then it comes right
back out and every single bit of it
comes out it doesn't sit up there and
get rank meanwhile Jessen does is like
quag you ladies don't allow the semen
inside that way it stays fresh sometimes
there's just those times you're just
like [ __ ] it just comes up not me now
are you girl woman no oh do you have any
almost got pregnant because I handle
this your plan B sure that's Plan B's
wants me know at this point I need a
punch card I should get a free one no
one ever warn me about okay so sharpie
obviously like Plan B is a hormone it
like overloads you with a certain it's
like taking like for birth control pills
at once yeah and like you know at least
say birth control can mess you up it
took me a while to realize there was one
time where I had you take Plan B because
no no no and I I was so like depressed
for two weeks
oh you guys have never taken ever take
it I know Gina's taken oh you know
oh yeah we're taking it tips like it's
like it's a baby's gonna come out I'm
gonna hang out it makes me handle it so
so so depressed and I just couldn't pull
myself out of it and it took me a minute
to realize it was like my PMS times
three and I was like I will never take
this [ __ ] again guys don't even realize
like everything we have to go through
like vaginally first you show up with
the dick and some soap I gotta shave it
I gotta like make sure it tastes good
and [ __ ] and then I gotta worry about
the contraceptive if you don't want to
use a condom like yeah the whole hormone
part of it that's sitting on us is like
it's pretty shitty and I don't know if
you guys have ever seen on Netflix
there's a series called sex explained
and it goes through like desire passion
all that stuff and then it goes into
like contraceptives and it goes into
like pregnancy and all this stuff if
you're a guy please watch that like
whole series because it's a very it's a
very good like basic start on all the
stuff that women have to do for their
bodies so maybe you'll understand a
little bit better why just please
[ __ ] use a condom like this or just
be exclusive so you don't you know and
then like let her I don't know the kind
of things suck but you got to do it
these oral contraceptives are hard on
this woman and I'm tired of hearing I
don't want to wear a condom they don't
feel good well it does not having sex
feel good doesn't a fortune feel good
yeah what I like it either
I got on birth control when I started
dating my guy because like this was like
okay this is [ __ ] serious so I felt
comfortable getting on birth control but
I started gaining weight like crazy and
I'm like am I really gonna stay here and
gained 15 pounds because it doesn't feel
good really like [ __ ] that dude and then
there was one time where I'm [ __ ] at
the waxing salon not over here straight
up with my Brazilian get you know I'm on
here is yeah she's got the the strip
mother dude I I didn't I don't know I
went I just was like okay I'm gonna get
away it's hard for darker skin tones no
I can get lays you can get the laser
skin because they said it could also
mess up your oh yeah that's a Fraxel
face laser but for these her hair
removal if I can do that but I just I
don't know I'm is getting a wax of time
and I'm over here like I really must
love this [ __ ] because he don't
got to get anything wax for me like
that's serious what does a guy have to
do that causes like pain or discomfort
in terms of satin literally nothing
nothing maybe like a maybe like a okay a
circumstance maybe I mean they don't
remember that [ __ ] get up when they're
older because they're 25 yeah he's just
an idiot yeah more getting um what is it
that thing where they singe the [ __ ]
what was it when it's [ __ ] ever the kids
anymore cool clothes don't work coming
for you yeah this ectomy burn I don't
think we cut it and burn it I don't
think they couldn't burn it I don't know
that we need a sex expert or know how
many [ __ ] dumbass men Shh in on him
that getting him so you could be talking
about this you know I know that have no
idea how a vasectomy works and there
looks like oh god no they're like oh no
it means I can never come again oh yeah
there's like doing it you can all come
it's just yeah the funny one too is that
they know that they could still come
it's just like I just don't want to be
shooting blanks why does it matter do
you want kids that's what you write in
like it's maybe not completely
reversible so I can understand why I'm
in charge freeze it in one of those
things yeah we pop out two and then we
flip a coin and whether I get these
[ __ ] tied up or you gets in they say
like snip right like yeah isn't it Joe I
think I don't know if it's legal in the
US I don't have it built with the gel
and into the dough like inject like this
permanent gel that's in the tube that
that takes the semen up I don't know if
that's in the u.s. though but that's a
non-decision yeah what if there was like
a little six-month treatment for it
because like we don't know if this is
gonna work out or not but let's have fun
I know right
so imagine it did you guys they got fat
and the guys like but I wonder if it
would take away from their experience
that like because when they come they
see like it's a certain color right so
what if they like what if you come in
and it's like clear but then what is it
denominator there's nothing to worry
about then why can't they enjoy that
much more that's like we know that [ __ ]
is not gonna come out clear name one
dude you know that drinks more than a
bottle of water there's this one time
like me and the psuedo stating we're
having sex and then my so years no me my
nose is bleeding no reason oh no and
then so just start bleeding and I was
like oh my god when he goes that's what
let's keep going I'm like alright
whatever and then the next day I was
rushing I had a photo shoot this is when
I had blonde hair and my hair stylist
was like oh my god hey I'm like what do
you mean she goes there's trying to
blood in your hair oh yeah explain that
I got some dry shampoo she's like well
we were [ __ ] I started bleeding and
then we just played and then come in
your face named for that oh I have to
tell you guys something so when we first
started this podcast and we were talking
about sex
if you mean in you listeners if you
scroll that can probably hear the way I
was talking about the type of sex I
liked or whatever Gina and Nikki were
always on the same page with a certain
kind of sex I was always kind of on a
different page of sex but since I've
been dating and experiencing some
different types of sex I have to update
you guys Oh Nikki Nikki you here thank
you off offset Miki offset guess who's
into choking now I'm team Nikki and
Jeana now I actually don't like choking
but I like being you like the rough
sleeping stomped and not being able to
move yeah
I know I'm team ruffnut maybe not like
food choke me with like an iron cord
type of sexual like Gina goes a little
too far but okay so this guy we're
making out and he starts doing the
choking thing right and I was like oh
wait I can't breathe
I was like okay this is weird but I
don't want to tell him what to do
because like I don't want to throw off
his game or anything and then like
[ __ ] 30 seconds later I was like oh
my [ __ ] god
he was like literally fisted my hair and
yanked it and I first I wanted to go you
a little [ __ ] [ __ ] like I
wanted a fight but then I didn't fight
and then I like because I didn't fight
then I was like oh right most guys when
they slapped my ass usually for most of
my life it's been like a bruises the
next day but honestly when I saw the
bruises in the mirror I was at home by
myself and I went manic so into this
roughs next thing now that I had sex
with another guy about a month later and
it was normal sex and then I went
alright I'm like can you hug me a little
like I was trying to grab his hand and
then like get it up towards my neck and
then he was just like no like he was not
down and I was like I was kind of sad
like I thought it was too nice see it's
great right I it's like once you go to
choking you can't go back true what's in
a club I like I want I just I'm not down
for the smacking and the slapping in the
he hasn't slapped me in my face yet so
as long I mean I don't think I did say
yet that I open to it I don't know you
stuff you come back with the missing
tooth
good love it's fine I'll get a veneer so
really I've been iris I recently started
learning like kind of easing into the
more dominant role yeah oh yeah which is
very different for me so there's this
new thing that I do now okay it's really
while riding him I take my panties that
I was wearing I shove it in his mouth
and I hold his mouth shut I'm like shut
the [ __ ] oh my god that is so I don't
know if okay so like I'm imagining
myself trying that with this guy that
does the choking so I don't think he
would be too oh my god I think you would
or like you panties and you take him off
and you wrap him around his penis and
you start stroking as I try to play
around with him a little bit I was like
oh if you don't finish your work I'm
gonna have to punish you and he
immediately he was like no I'm gonna
punish you okay he's not down for
remember back in the day well I don't
know if you guys remember but like NASA
feels like the other we would talk about
sex and stuff it's a different show so
back then I brought up how I liked
putting a pillow over that in the
comments section okay I'll explain so
back then when I was trying to explain
my reasoning I was really timid and I
was like still trying to like figure out
how to articulate how I felt about it
and the reasons why I would do it and it
just came out all wrong but anyway back
then I used to like having sex like on
top like I would be writing Casey yeah I
would be writing him and then like I'll
just grab the pillow and like cover his
head like suffocating him yes so the
thing is back then I explained it as a
way cuz like I said I just didn't know
how to really articulate it so back then
I said it was because like I was
self-conscious and I didn't want him I
don't want him to see me and like that
was how I articulated that but it wasn't
really it that wasn't the reason it was
kind of hot to me to kind of dominate
over him and I
kind of be like now you can't see this
kind of thing you know so I was just
kind of like that was a I enjoyed that
for some time and he actually loved that
[ __ ] he he really likes getting rid of
like his senses
so whenever like sometimes I'll use
blindfolds and or like you know tying up
and [ __ ] like he likes like not being in
control so he's a little bit nuts down
to imagine I take the other side so well
oh it's you guys are kind of like
switches yeah I would like putting a
pillow over my guy's face because I'm
basically saying to him like I'm
literally just using you for your
[ __ ] body you're just a stick yes the
approach that was happening but also
back then I was just also really
self-conscious and timid about my
sexuality so I didn't even with Casey
like I was kind of trying to do that but
it not fully like diving deep in in how
I felt about it but yeah like for him
that's why it like he was the one that
introduced like the whole choking thing
and once he started doing cuz then
that's him like dominating over me so
I'm like oh [ __ ] yeah like keep going
don't make me breathe like this [ __ ]
this is [ __ ] wild yeah I'm telling
y'all for years it's [ __ ] fantastic
I'm so glad you guys are finally you're
with me I'm telling you guys that you
should be switches everyone please just
go home one night just a little bit just
dominate a little bit like if you ever
just like grab a guy like by is like
face and you just start talking like mad
[ __ ] to him he's like I'm sorry I'm like
yeah you [ __ ] want it don't you oh
[ __ ] I kind of felt like I was dominant
over Joe for the last five years so I'm
really enjoying being like submissive
now just someone who's like a [ __ ]
strong man this is like the whole like
dominance which right now is like new
grounds for me to it's completely new to
me like the first time that happened
like don't hate this you graduated yeah
also now just like be a good boy come
for me I'm telling you it's so fun and
then like also it adds you like okay be
on a switch especially when you find a
significant other this is a switch it
adds a whole other dimension to your
relationship because like okay so let's
say that you cuz I know you said you
like the sex of this guy but you're like
what I date him I don't know like
imagine you guys did date and now for
the rest of your life your sex is always
you getting dominated
but then like what if it's a little
unpredictable like and you guys just
know obviously like of your mood like
one week you're talking because you
haven't read like we've just like we've
just cracked the surface right so and
I'm enjoying that dynamic right now but
I totally get what you're saying like
eventually maybe to try different things
but then also I don't know like because
maybe some people do get caught in their
same patterns like the same guy like
like how guys are like you can never do
but stuff on me you know like it's
almost like what if he never wants to be
dominated by a woman then it's like oh
dude I'm still trying to unlock the but
I'm locked it on my ex it was fine the
male g-spot is in the butt yeah I have
to go inside of it yeah you see that's
what I'm trying games like the taint and
that's it yeah you don't have you ever
access access to the but maybe like a
finger really if I get more it in the
future well aged and I'm like okay fine
we got plenty of foods in there sex we
had a few right now I'm trying to
navigate to that ass like I feel like
once you enter a guy's butt like he will
like stay with you forever because it's
almost like you you crossed that line he
can't he can't ever be with another
woman dude he can't even cross that line
with himself so yes not only I cross
that line but that we criss cross them
yeah let you sodomized them you can't go
anywhere else a girl can find the g-spot
and make you think nasty things that
only I can do for you yeah cuz he'll
never ask another girl to do it's like
job security ever done I didn't sign an
NDA yeah stay with me now
almost like basketball players and
rappers la yeah 50 cent or somebody like
one of the female rappers called and I
was saying like oh you like it in a but
I can't remember who it was someone
called word to call that on me like an
yeah [ __ ] dope I don't know I feel
like I guess is kind of like a shameful
thing for guys I mean it's not supposed
to be but like some guys kind of grow up
with you give it another 10 years
give it another 10 years it's gonna be
so much more socially accepted I'm just
trying to access the but but with your
finger not with them yeah yeah yeah what
what not with your mouth right and done
that before and it's like I don't really
think it does much for either party like
oh that's not true it's whatever review
it does something for you know not know
it does something for the guy guys like
guys that rim jobs [ __ ] love those
rim jobs really yeah I think it just
wasn't he probably he was probably too
scared he wasn't he wasn't ready for it
mhm
he didn't allow himself to I know a guy
who who made up with a girl like off
like a tinder date whatever and then her
face was cute but she was actually a lot
chubby or in person no no he was just
like [ __ ] and then like they drunkenly
hooked up and she does ramli shoved her
tongue on his butt he's like whoa okay
like like all the way and just dude the
mom on the prostate is right around the
rim of the bottle is like right like I'm
talking like maybe like penis this far
oh yeah that's like that's [ __ ] it
dude that's where it's at and like I
don't understand why I can't access the
but like you don't even have to and why
is it that like my butt is a conquest
but your butt is off-limits yeah yeah
that is true
really like why like why they literally
shove them in there like are you okay
with me doing that that's right up in
oh my god that's true cuz I guess for me
my butthole is completely off limits
like don't go and whale it oh nothing
like just now that I've been there I
hated it never like I'm good even like a
knuckle of the thumb goes not even as
nothing okay dude nothing what about a
little bug no girl nothing could go in a
dude I want one of those little like
diamond a jewel you know cute it looks
so cute Oh like if I was a submissive
and tied up and I've got like a little
jewel in my butt and I'm like like then
I would do stood one of my friends has a
tail it's like a butt plug yeah there's
a guy that asked you for a tail once
like [ __ ] how the [ __ ] am I supposed to
wear that [ __ ] out in public when you
want me to wear this [ __ ] oh no just
walk around the house and swing that
little bit around you know take some
cute photos I haven't tried it yet but I
mean I'm open to it I don't they look
massive though no but then like
something a little smaller to start with
no once it goes in its just your butt
hole closed back to normal oh okay so
you just go but it looks really big
until it gets in yeah I tried noon and
do you guys know a newman's I've heard
of it before it is it's it's kind of a
weight loss app but it's not your
typical will exercise and do this or you
know just here's your diet plan for
today it's actually a motivator that
kind of tries to change your psychology
of you know what what exactly got us to
this healthy habits yeah helps you
develop and cement healthy habits into
your life so it's not just a 30 day
weight loss plan like this is supposed
to be for life whether it takes you 30
days 60 days or 90 days to adapt these
habits it literally changes your life
forever so you get to actually set
specific goals like eating better like
feeling better having more energy
actually trying to enjoy your exercise
or like feeling good about your choices
like not just eating a healthy moving
food and being like oh I did that but
finishing that and feeling good about it
and feeling proud about yourself and not
being afraid to say hey
job for doing that so it's based on
psychology and new teaches you why you
do the things that you do and then
empowers you with the tools to break the
bad habits and have better ones so and
everyone's busy
and that's why noon doesn't demand much
of your time they only ask for five
minutes 10 minutes 10 minutes 24 hours
in the day you've got time for you
so you're assigned a goal specialist and
you're matched up with a community of
other numerous so there's always support
and people going through the same things
you are
it's the perfect time to make the choice
to have healthier habits so sign up for
your trial today at noon dot-com slash
big mood what do you have to lose guys
just visit new com such big mood to
start your child today that's new calm /
big mood in oom calm and you know what
boy guys ever ever ever played best
fiends I just downloaded it I haven't
started it yet but I got again we're
telling me about it was like oh my god
this is how I'm gonna waste my love this
app and I'm not even exactly he hasn't
eaten in days guys I've been playing
best fiends for many years now it's been
like a good four I know you won't stop
talking about every time we're at the
airport she's like died from playing
best fiends as I need to keep playing
so best fiends is a mobile puzzle game
so wherever you are you can bust this
baby out and exercise your brain so it's
a free download and like I said it's a
it's a puzzle so your end up using these
tiny little theme characters in order to
help you crack the code crack the puzzle
and each fiend character has its own
special powers to help you and I'm
telling you I've been addicted to this
thing I'm on level 293 now I am just not
I can't stop playing this game and talk
to your son and weeks they you know they
have like I have talked to my son he
actually joins me he plays best fiends
on the iPad while I play it on my phone
so we love this game so there's over
2000
levels so I was never anything Wow yeah
it's never-ending and they have these
really really pretty visuals too so it's
like and then they also have like the
story you can follow and seasonally
they'll have special puzzles for you to
accomplish I'm telling I really love
this game so it does not require
internet to play so it's perfect for
when I'm traveling on the airplane I
spend all like six hours of them if I
have a really long flight I'm just
playing this game so I played anywhere
how to flight today so engage your brain
with fun puzzles and collect tons of Q
characters trust me with over 100
million downloads this five-star rated
mobile puzzle game is a must play
download best fiends for free on the
Apple App Store or Google Play
that's friends without the are best
fiends guys I love it you're gonna love
it too you're gonna be addicted and
don't blame me if you don't get anything
any work done anyway I'm gonna start
playing it in our fault I really am one
download flight in Vegas yeah like Vegas
Vegas I'm going next week [ __ ] oh
buttholes oh I'm ready to access the
butthole you like it might be a little
more acceptable in like 10 years or so I
feel like yeah we're still coming off of
that I don't want to be gay oh dude you
know what I also know I was guests on a
podcast the other day and they were
telling me the three girls were telling
me making drinks what's up she was
telling me how there's a [ __ ] sex toy
that's amazing and like all three of
them loved him apparently like you can
shape it however you want and Bend it
however you want
oh yeah and then it's Bluetooth and then
there's songs that you can download and
it vibrates to the songs and they're
like did you download the Christmas
dragon like one two [ __ ] jingle right
yeah I understand and then like they
have like different songs as [ __ ] and
like you can set what it vibrates to and
I was like this sounds of like insane
you guys like that though cuz I don't
like the patterned vibration I don't
I always let my vibrator and a really
yeah and then and then also I'm so
boring I have like one spot that does it
for doing I just put it on the like the
lightest setting and on that one spot
and I'm like it's like a little angelic
just buzzing my guy and like I felt
comfortable actually like masturbating
in front of him like because that's
super normal during sex like mud the guy
on wood now he is the first person to
ever make the finishing texts like the
first and the only person yeah so but
g-spot sorry just talked about this
before for some reason g-spot orgasms
are just like not as intense sometimes
I recently had my first one they're
amazing credit oh my god Casey like he
he's the first one that and only one
that's ever made me [ __ ] during sex but
that's because like a certain angles
rubbing the clip I've never had an
orgasm and like I said I just found it
and and then after that I was taking
this yoga class
like many weeks after and we're doing
like core work oh no oh my glass go on
vacation actually exercise no no no it
does not during vacation is after
vacation I'm at a yoga class we're doing
a class
yeah like class pass though and and then
like so I didn't I didn't orgasm from it
in the in the class but then like that
tingling sensation like I knew where to
find it now or else
Wow that's what Kate Kegel exercises are
helping so you're kind of unlocking the
Kegel Kegel a little bit cool and you
said that I was like
I'm holding it right now oh yeah I know
okay good you know what actually helps I
kind of figured out the the penis angle
if it's kind of obviously I think we all
kind of know it should be pointed up so
like like coming in and then back up
towards your belly button but also it
doesn't have to go that far in it only
needs to be a couple of inches in but
another thing that helps is that if the
the base of the penis is kind of pushing
against your [ __ ] so like you know
how you have the hole and then you have
your little girl taint and then you have
your [ __ ] like if the base of the
dick is like pointed down kind of
pushing pushing towards yours as well
like mine is like on my back like that
well it doesn't have to be missionary
even if it's some they'll do I'll be on
top you can Cal doggystyle
so like the the the if the dick is hard
and it's like pushing it's like pushing
you're hoping you're having with your
bottle orgasm because it is not is it it
helped my swear to God yeah thank you
having a bubble it's like pushing the
butthole but then it's also like angled
to where it's hitting your g-spot inside
so it's like it's just the angle but if
it's pushing against your butthole helps
a whole lot my title of this episode is
just your butthole or mine the guy that
I started dating yeah it's all about the
angle and like he learned my angle so
like when me like when we finish we
always just like when when I when it's
time the finishing move yeah he puts me
in the finisher and like I started like
I haven't orgasm every single time I
apparently can score I mean not to like
outdo Gina what's your name again
Goldeneye the one shot the double shot
double shot I'll do the double shot or
anything but it's all about the angle
and like really what's your angle is
that at the side is a really good angle
to dude it is it's what we've talked
about this before this the size of the
dick does not matter because the g-spot
is maybe like 2 to 3 inches and
depending on the girl yes like times of
dicks too long and it goes right past us
and he knows he doesn't he can't even
put the whole thing in you're like you
only do like half of it and like he
knows exactly where the spot is but you
know it's also up to us to be
comfortable with telling the guy like
exactly where it is
trying to push your [ __ ] brains out
and you're like wait but if you just
back up yeah yeah I'm trying to but you
don't want to like kill their power you
know you like yeah get it daddy but then
you're shooting right past them
yeah but they want they want to make you
finish you tell them where it is like
back up just a little bit right there
okay right there there's only been one
guy like for me before my squirting was
just for shows like hey you wanna see
something cool real quick oh geez
yeah just like all right it's cool it's
a cool thing there's actually only been
one guy who makes me involuntarily so
good ready for it yeah you can feel it
yeah oh yeah I don't feel it when it's
happening Oh cuz like I have a lot
sometimes sometimes I don't know I'm
literally never squirted I'm so mad like
dude we'll finish and I'm like oh look
at the wall yeah my headboard a whole
spray never good yeah there's a certain
England self squares when I'm
masturbating sometimes huh I'm like
sometimes I feel like it got a pee
they're like wait I make him stop and
then I go into my bladder that's the
thing so if that's what it feels like
yeah that's what it kind of feels like I
don't know if it's coming from the
similar place
I don't know my yeah there's probably
sounds a little bit but I think if you
like pee before like I always pee before
so yeah cuz I don't want to get anxious
about that sensation so there's
literally nothing in there clean slate
and then when it comes time for the you
know it just I can't even
yeah I don't know what they're I don't
know sir I guess I don't have the thing
there's like a certain angle he figured
it out it's when we're missionary he has
one of my legs on his shoulder straight
up and the other leg yields his side oh
the sign yeah and then and then when he
first did that I squirted involuntarily
whoa hold on I didn't plan for that yeah
just I didn't plan for that and then he
was like did you squirm like yeah I'm
very surprised myself too and now it and
then it just became like a like a yeah
I'm like something I just visualize
right now you know those carnival games
you have to like squirt
blow the balloon out craters are
squirting yeah
gross yeah we're like I didn't edit I
never feel it when it even while like
I'm looking at it it's happening I don't
feel like like coming out oh yeah well
like of course it's attractive for guys
because like I'm trying to think like if
if we had sex with guys and like there
was no physical finisher you know I
would feel kind of like okay that was
fine so this is certainly weird so for
me when it comes to sex I don't need to
orgasm any every time saying yeah so
then like but then whenever whenever
that happens the guys always like open I
feel terrible but I'm like dude don't
well it was great for me it was like
because you could go on for literally
like ten days straight he could keep
going and I'm just like I get off when
you get exactly please come and I will
be satisfied same like that's that to me
is my finish shirt yeah seeing him
finish and I'm like II did a good job
okay see that's girls booty I said same
that it's in case he comes with huge no
dude I haven't done the pillow thing for
a long time because of like I got I got
self-conscious of it because it was all
over the JK comments like for everything
for my Instagram on my Twitter like
people were like poor Casey save Casey
like he's just no Casey was asking for
it yeah yeah like poor Casey's getting
suffocated he should be able to see what
boring as [ __ ] during sex boring yeah
they were literally saying that I was
bored because whatever but your mom you
gotta you gotta put the pillow over his
head tonight be like you can't look at
my tits until you make me finish [ __ ]
hell yeah half the people watching this
they'd be like yeah I want that to
happen it's like a challenge with a
little reward at the end yeah nice yeah
here's one actually make eye contact
called it's a [ __ ] losers oh I knew
it
oh man I had some really creepy sex with
this guy that was making eye contact the
whole time and then I felt like I had a
nightmare about it like
I sorta guy he was looking deep into my
eyes and I was like wait a minute this
is only for someone you're in love with
this is not for one night stand with I
was like oh my god this is [ __ ]
creepy dude I can only do eye contact
with my guy right now occasionally
because I literally just like just I
like when the eye contact happens right
now like yeah we were alive that looks
like my man's eyes right I was like I
was like damp but yeah there was one
time that we started making eye contact
and I was like oh my god I'm about to
have the biggest orgasm of my life it's
too powerful it's like if it's with a
stranger it is so creepy for me it was
yeah creepy but then if it's like with
someone you love it's like superpower
too powerful though like honestly I
don't even need all that like this it's
so cute that I was dating he doesn't
like it from behind he's because like
and I learned this like a little bit
into our relationship he's like I don't
like it from behind I'm like why cuz I
like to look at still dirty as [ __ ]
though you know but why it's really
sweet it's but we still have our dirty
sex but it's like it's kind of sweet see
like that's cute
dude I know like I realize um like Casey
and I don't do a lot of eye contact but
the times that we have and it's been
more recently I'm like oh this is nice
but usually I really like it when he's
like in my neck yeah one of my friends
was telling me cuz I I think I right now
like I guess emotionally where I'm at I
prefer to be a little bit emotionally
distant and like you know my friend was
telling me something that this guy did
to her and I was like I want that to
happen to me so bad she said this guy
came her this guy she was dating came
home just like they were in the bedroom
he just bent her over he pulled his belt
off wrapped it around her waist
tightened the SH out of it was [ __ ]
her like like while he was holding the
belt around her waist I was like I want
that kind of sex right now
they pulled the belt off I was like okay
around her waist yeah like he [ __ ]
looped it through the thing pulled it
tight and then held that using her from
behind I was like yeah the crack from
the yeah oh no no yeah I would not I
could not that's like an actual one time
we took a fetish quiz all of us yeah we
did it was so funny because I sent you
guys the link but I didn't know it was
giving you my results I was insulted
like it literally was the link to my
results on stream but they didn't see
the screen
I was like wait why are the results
already but they did see you thank God I
was like oh my god we should do a whole
episode [ __ ] out that's actually how I
found it because it was all my feed my
Twitter feed someone else posted their
results and I'm like what is this well
let's do it when I try us out I trade in
our actual results I tried taking the
quiz and I didn't finish it because I
was literally answering no - it was
super long and I just like I'm actually
not into any of this stuff I was like I
am so boring yeah just I was like just
[ __ ] kind of like the bruising part of
it now so I'm like gosh if I get too
addicted to that you're gonna walk
around I'm gonna be just progressively
gets worse one day she's missing a whole
[ __ ] that's great but we'll do it as an
episode funny thing is I like the
restraint and everything but the thing
is I don't like the pain like I don't
like her I noticed I like a little bit
of just a little bit of it but it's and
I never maybe because I hadn't
experienced it myself
I'm loving is it this is laughing oh my
god
is it the slapping motion or do you
actually like get punch or like one
handed it's always open so he was
pulling my hair that was painful but
while it's like pain here and also his
dick was so big that it was like kind of
like opening my [ __ ] vagina it was
like a sight it was like this like a
closed circuit if you guys ever had sex
in your cervix is hurting yes dude that
[ __ ] sucks dude that's been it I don't
like me I mean like what's happening
either it's too big it's going to do
portal you're not ready like you're you
haven't like worked up it doesn't
compute with me or my cutting angle no
angles we've done in the past same
person you might have to go to ram ready
so I'm like what is happening yeah
endometriosis I've had it the first time
ever had that was like junior year he
was also really really tight - it
actually hurt sorry - I would be like in
like fetal position in pain for like
four days straight because it just feels
like it feels like you're trying to pass
gas but it won't come out and it just
like swells up inside you and it [ __ ]
hurts and I thing is the pain like it
radiates to your butthole oh yeah which
is it may not necessarily even be
medical a lot of times it could be
psychological - dude it was this one
time like period of time where I was
going to the gyno because like I said it
was like really close yeah like it was
not going in and like I was I was turned
on I wanted to go and like you're
sickening and it got to the point where
my doctor said you should buy these
dilators oh my god like oh yeah she did
like tests and I was perfectly fine I
didn't have any bacteria or any
infection or anything was
medical so yeah and then like looking
back on it I'm like well yeah we were
having issues around that time my body
just reacted to it even though like I
didn't I wasn't conscious of it my body
knew like you ain't trying to [ __ ] this
dude right now no [ __ ] well we could sit
here and talk about our vaginas all day
but alas the episode has ended Fein
haven't any labia huh want to throw that
out there yeah we were talking with John
isn't any labia look like you know like
the labia minora or a Jorah majora
minora people are or is the little flaps
right some people are out east and some
people are in ease and then I was like
this is we've seen your vagina wait but
I haven't seen inside of it he's never
been like oh like the two fat hamburger
lips I've never seen like the actual
inside like the lettuce radishes for
that like it's so beautiful yeah you
show us yeah sure we thank you guys so
much
we'll see you naked been watching
listening